[Music]
in a father news [ __ ] this is a good
topic for me submitted by DJ salad the
fight is never a professor allegedly
poisoned his wife and daughter using a
yoga ball filled with carbon monoxide
that's one of these [ __ ] right
here right knocks I didn't killed them
down that's on Walter White [ __ ] right
there
[ __ ] I gotta read it twice there's a lot
of big words in there carbon monoxide is
that the the the car exhaust a sleepy
gas that makes you just sleep and I'm
inside of my yoga ball yeah just pumped
it in there and let it slowly leak out
in the room it was actually two yoga
balls
oh he filled two yoga balls but he left
one of the balls unplugged in the trunk
of his wife's yellow Mini Cooper also
she was driving she died they shouldn't
I got a mini SUV that's plenty of space
yeah so this takes place in Hong Kong
you guys suppose that British influences
shared dude all your people are named
[ __ ] Winston hi my name is Winston
[Music]
what's did Winston late yeah my name is
calden well this dude's name is car cam
son this his name 53 years old so he was
a former [ __ ] him son Oh call him son so
he he was a former anesthesiology
professor and now he's accused of murder
so he this all happened back in 2015 but
right now he's going through the whole
court proceeding so that's why it's
making headlines and so you killed his
whole family the tribe has two daughters
he killed one of them and it seems like
he killed her by accident because he
didn't know that she was gonna be out of
school that day it was meant for her mom
yeah Oh
[ __ ] you trying to kill his
mother-in-law no his wife is wife oh the
mother of the daughter Oh button the
daughter came out of school that day and
drove that car as she dies no they died
together so the mom and the daughter
died it seems like from what they're
piecing together here that the the
husband father didn't realize that the
daughter was gonna be out of school that
day so she he didn't know that she was
gonna join her mom oh but it won't be
the same if it's just a daughter such an
empty house even if I hated my wife I'd
be like [ __ ] we have another daughter
saying oh no I mean yeah but does too so
it's like if you have two and there's
only one and it's just you and her just
eating [ __ ] Cheerios in the morning
and it's like what's up I think that
happens he Marquez you've murdered his
daughter and his wife they know that
later what day in that head of yours bro
thinking about the next day Matt none
you know like not when they found out
the story but they can solve this point
in your in your head it's - yeah she
died and they just and then the next day
it's not the same and then they're
getting like Chinese cereal and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they shouldn't have got into fish I
blame yoga yeah I blame yoga just don't
do Fitness damn so it feels like
prosecutors are arguing that he was
having an affair with a student yes
wife knew about it and so they they're
being like estranged and that the wife
had made some peace with her husband's
mistress as she did but she did not want
to get a divorce so then that's when
his head like he was like well let me
remover completely in kill her marry her
I don't know I wanted to marry his
student I don't know they don't mention
that part but there are saying that so
the daughter was 16 oh they have an
older daughter as 22 years old the wife
was 47 that's sad man damn he doesn't
look like a killer nope he's like I had
a killer but don't put me
sixteen-year-old daughter Oh what was
the mom and this is no mom was before
her and the moms got some strong genes
who's that
they all look like the mom yeah they
straight a bit like the mom how do you
get caught
that is true like that's a really clever
way to kill someone he is an
anesthesiologist professor he's like
he's a Walter white dude oh so he knows
what's up yeah so first they thought
that there was a malfunction malfunction
with the car but then they ruled Oh like
the catalytic converter was [ __ ] up
and then it was just leaking like hard
on the outside that's what they thought
because the mom and the daughter they
were found parts somewhere unconscious
in the front seats and a jogger was open
up our dog no oh just let's just take a
nap inside this car for a second what a
responsible jogger cuz I would have if I
saw I would just play all there was
taking a nap well she she thought that
they were taking a nap with the thing
that was the red flag was that the
windshield wipers were on and it wasn't
raining
maybe the little girl passed out first
and she's like oh [ __ ] and she pulled
over I don't she went damn it's so scary
damn I would have suspected the yoga
ball likewise their yoga ball my card
you know what's [ __ ] up - well he
juggle balls in my car so let's say she
did so this is all still happening right
it hasn't been confirmed for a fact that
he was the one that killed them so let's
just say he did kill them it's so [ __ ]
up that he's saying that the daughter
may have used the yoga ball in the car
is her own suicide plot so he's trying
to pin it on his dead daughter yeah
doesn't want to take responsibility for
it well how is it how is it who's woman
said it was him well the authorities the
Chinese the Hong Kong police they're
like hey this is who I accused man we
have to refer to them as Hong Kong
police and not just because they're not
real policemen you guys are wondering
why we're like he's claiming that she
got the carbon monoxide is that they
were using it to fight a rat problem in
the home whoa that's not your rap homes
in Hong Kong
maybe that's how you feel my gate and
gas [ __ ] I don't know I think so I think
it's like they don't got enough money
like take care of the rat problem buddy
got enough money to go to yoga class I'm
not understanding that's as expensive as
hell yeah I mean like that's not
expensive to take care of a couple rats
you just buy a couple traps get some
cheese I wouldn't even know where to buy
that just like cartoons the trap no
carbon monoxide so they do have that
sure the traps like in Hong Kong like do
they have a carbon monoxide store that
you could fill up a tank with and you
just spray that co2 no just Co it's like
the co yeah
that's why the dad is the easiest
culprit cuz that's one job you probably
had a session all the time you know what
the real culprit is that sweet ass
University [ __ ]
that [ __ ] makes a man go crazy
you know what I mean
if I was a further I want to take up a
job at a university that is too tempting
new new class and every year new clients
University [ __ ] okay and it did this
is great
that's [ __ ] treacherous professor on
the first day you just sweating bullets
oh god oh god somebody help me please
see [ __ ] everywhere I'll be like damn
man Oh
sweating [ __ ] bricks right now ah
[ __ ] [ __ ]
my god you're a [ __ ] comedian dude it
would've been jails so fast and he
starts stretching call me mercy huh you
start teaching coffee at university
funny pussy's here now choose like a
humanities course or like sociology or
something that's where all the hot girls
are you got to be an engineer or
something engineering class you'd be
fine yeah they're just depending on the
engineer female oh but no no that's the
stereotype though there's only like one
girl in every engineering department the
whole wife didn't even though when they
look in the mirror I can't I can't say
anything preach the university like
stereotype is like so all the more
liberal arts and humanities and those
kind of classes have like the cuter
girls in the group and in the math and
science department typically they'll be
like and then I'm in the business of
business courses the business you have
like good-looking people I think in
general though like that's just the
stereotype we still do college shows and
[ __ ] and straight up don't you depending
on the organizations that bring you out
yep yep you can
nobody's all are true yeah you're
offended at college that you spoke at
cuz I did my last one it was pretty bad
well what did you do I did like is the
Asian persuasion and Beijing celebration
in Chicago was one of those Oh in
Chicago I know that one and they brought
me out cuz they're like oh here just
look at this college and it was great so
we brought you out to this one and I
went imagination is what you went to
possibly yeah I think we did one of
those too you know but it was one it was
like very private there was no other
perform it was just one person
so what same way okay so I did it and
they wanted to speak about like I was
like what's what's troubled here like
and they're like oh the the racism of
like white people assuming that we're
this way and it's like ridiculous and
then one guy was like this is the people
up pick me up when I was like good
that's why I try to keep like two white
friends at least cuz they they and I
that messed me up cuz I was like I think
there's racism within this crew yeah
yeah all right so I didn't want to hear
the truth and I think that's what the
problem was I might offended them what
did you think this group of people were
racist and I meant the whole audience it
was just a racist insecurities huh yeah
they wanted to find it that was about
the difference and that's what I noticed
from a lot of insecure little people's
like I'm gonna talk about midgets
insecure in their own like self in the
group like when I travel out of state
I feel like California breeds a
different kinds of kind of Asian cuz we
we don't really have to find ourselves
or like I don't know like but then out
in other universities that we speak to
the there's like a collection of Asian
kids that grew up around a lot of white
kids and then they they grew old vets
they grew up denying their Asian asst
and then when they go to university meet
other Asian kids and then they're like
they find other Asian kids that are
proud of being Asian and they're like oh
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I got to
hurry up and be Asian too cuz I've been
denying it all my life and then like
they just have this weird identity thing
that's going on that I don't really
understand growing up here in Carter for
like somebody like you to just because
like I think like your
your brand in general is just so nice
yeah these are very nice to watch
because if I come out to a show they're
just like that's what they expect out of
you they expect yeah like I literally
just [ __ ] just roast the [ __ ] out of
people when I come through and they just
[ __ ] these take it it's like I didn't
come out to do a show they just want me
to be inspiring and I was like okay so
let's talk about oh I even got into
school no that also offended a lot of
people and how pointless it was but I
was trying I didn't want to waste time
like I was like no that's the truth or
you guys wanted I heard a lot of chronic
[ __ ] loser and people refuse to speak
at schools now because of that reason
like they just want it to be like an
echo chamber of their beliefs and if you
don't fit that narrative then or would
give us something from your video that's
what they were they wanted to do
breakdancing I believe I made people cry
before straight up crying oh man I got
this email to speak and talk to me for a
call for this for this like Asian
American group right and then they're
like hey Joe I wanna I wanna see if you
can do this interview on how you had a
hard time in college and the racism that
you dealt with and I'm like what are you
talking about brawls like I'm blessed to
have gone to college and the
opportunities that I've got in all this
[ __ ] and I got [ __ ] free money from
this government I'm like I didn't face
no racism I had nothing but support and
I'm like why you looking for this kind
of [ __ ] like why are you looking for
people to blame and all that and I
[ __ ] [ __ ] lectured him like a Asian
bad over email
[Music]